we're asked to identify the percent
amount and base in this problem and they
asked us 150 is 25% of what number they
don't ask us to solve it but it's too
tempting so what I want to do is first
answer this question that they're not
even asking us to solve but first I want
to answer this question and then we can
think about what the percent the amount
and the base is because those are just
just words those are just definitions
the important thing is to be able to
solve a problem like this
so they're saying 150 they're saying 150
is 25% of what number or another way to
view this 150 is 25% of some number so
let's if we say that X so let's let X X
is equal to the number the number that
150 is 25% of right that's what we need
to figure out 150 is 25% of what number
that number right here we're seeing is X
so that tells us that if we start with X
and if we were to take 25% of X if we
were to take 25% of X so 25% of X you
could imagine this same thing as
multiplying it by 25% which is the same
thing as multiplying it if you view it
as a decimal times 0.25 times X these
two statements are identical so if you
start with that number you take 25% of
it or you multiply it by 0.25 that is
going to be equal to 150 that is going
to be equal to 150 150 is 25% of this
number and then you can solve for X so
let's just start with this one over here
so if we just have if let me just write
it separately so you understand what I'm
doing 0.25 times some number is equal to
150 now there's two ways we can do this
we can divide both sides of this
equation by 0.25 or if you recognize
that well you know four quarters make a
dollar you could say let's multiply both
sides of this equation by
or you could do either one I'll do the
first because that's how we normally do
algebra problems like this but so let's
just multiply both by 0.25 multiply this
times or multiply it by 0.25 that will
just be an X and then the right-hand
side will be 150 divided by 0.25 and the
reason why I want to do this it really
is this good practice dividing by a
decimal so let's do that so we want to
figure out what a hundred fifty divided
by 0.25 is and we've done this before
when you divide by a decimal what you
can do is you can make the number that
you're dividing into the nut other
number you can turn this into a whole
number by essentially shifting the
decimal two to the right but if you do
that for the number in the denominator
you also do it to the numerator so right
now this is you could view this as one
hundred fifty point zero zero two five
times 100 you're shifting the decimal
two to the right then you'd also have to
do that with 150 so then it becomes 15
thousand shifted two to the right so our
decimal place becomes like this
so 150 divided by 0.25 is the same thing
as fifteen thousand divided by 25 and
let's just work it out really fast so 25
goes into doesn't go into fit doesn't go
into one doesn't go into 15 it goes into
150 what is that six times right it goes
into 100 four times so it goes in 150
six times six times six times 0.25 is or
actually this is now 25 we've shifted
the decimal the decimal sitting right
over there
so six times 25 is 150 you subtract you
get no remainder bring down this 0 right
here 25 goes into 0 zero times zero
times 25 is zero subtract no remainder
bring down this last zero 25 goes into 0
zero times zero times 25 is zero
subtract no remainder so 150 divided by
0.25 is equal to 600 and you might have
been able to do that in your head
because when we were at this point in
our equation 0.25 X is equal to 150 you
could have just multiplied both sides of
this equation times 4 4 times 0.25
five is the same thing as 4 times 1/4
which is a whole and 4 times 150 is 600
so you would have gotten it either way
and this makes total sense because 100
150 is 25% of some number that means 150
should be 1/4 of that number it should
be a lot smaller than the number and it
is 150 is 1/4 of 600 now let's answer
their actual question identify the
percent identify the percent well it
looks like 25% that's the percent is 25%
the amount and the base in this problem
and based on how they're wording it I
assume amount means when you take the
25% of the base so they're saying that
the amount is my best sense of it is
that the amount is equal to the percent
is equal to the percent times the base
times the base let me do the basin of
green so the base is the number you're
taking the percent of the amount is the
the the quantity that that percentage
represents so here we already saw the
percent the percent is 25% that's the
percent the number that we're taking 25%
of or the base is the base is X you know
this right here what number X these are
that is the base the value of it is 600
we figured it out and the amount is 150
this right here is the amount the amount
is 150 150 is 25% of the base of 600 the
important thing is how do you solve this
problem
you know the words themselves you know
that those are all really just
definitions